is it even possible or logical for our
federal government to pay off this debt
and operate debt free mathematically we
could I don't think we have the
political um willpower to do it because
as soon as you tell um your Uncle Henry
who gets a A subsidy because he runs a
dairy farm from the US government that
he's not going to get that subsidy
anymore because we're cutting our
expenses then he's not going to vote for
that congressman and that congressman is
going to get get replaced by a
congressman who will spend money like
he's a drunken
Congressman right yeah and so the people
won't they don't they they want to they
they in theory a lot of people say I'd
like to balance the budget I'd like to
get the the income to at least equal the
where we're not going further in debt
but to do that would require cutting a
lot of things out and the problem is
we're so far in debt now that a big
portion of the budget is just the
interest on the old debt